today let's examine how you can use the
IBM cloud app service to get started
building cloud native applications and
deploy to kubernetes on IBM cloud the
IBM cloud app service offers a guided
approach to creating new cloud
applications and it lets you start
building your new apps in just a matter
of minutes well start by clicking on the
get started button on the IBM cloud app
service web page the first step is to
select the appropriate starter kit based
on the application we want to build
there our starter kits available for
building both web apps and micro
services using popular languages
including Java Swift Python and nodejs
in this case we're going to select the
Java Web App with spring we're going to
go ahead and click the Create app button
we're going to give our app a name we're
gonna select a resource group we'll go
ahead and hit create our basic project
has now been created and here we have
the ability to start adding services or
resources iBM has a host of services
that you can use in this case let's
select a database
and we'll pick Cloudant we'll select a
region a resource group and a pricing
plan will stick with light for now
as you can see the Cloudant database
service has been configured and added to
a project now that we have the service
added we're ready to setup the DevOps
toolchain for kubernetes deployment we
can do this by clicking on configure
continuous delivery the first step in
setting up our DevOps tool chain is
selecting a deployment method we have a
few options here we can deploy to IBM
kubernetes service deploy a cloud
foundry or deploy to a virtual server in
this case let's target our cluster you
can select which cluster you'd like to
target and then click Next then we can
enter a tool chain name region and
resource group and then click create
this will configure the DevOps tool
chain and create a private git
repository for starter application code
this process also binds your IBM cloud
services to your kubernetes cluster so
that authentication credentials will be
bound to the cluster and available in
your kubernetes secrets here we can see
that the tool chain has been created and
added to our project let's click on the
view tool chain button to see exactly
what it's doing
here we see all the tools that were
configured in the previous steps it
includes the private git repository the
Eclipse Orion web IDE for accessing your
code when you're not on your primary
workstation and the delivery pipeline
let's click delivery pipeline to get a
detailed look at how its configured our
pipeline includes a build stage a deploy
stage and a health stage any changes to
the repositories master branch will
trigger the pipeline and the pipeline's
deploy stage performs a kubernetes
deployment using the helm chart that
exists as part of the application source
tree you can also click on add stage to
customize for your needs and your
workflows now that our projects been
created we're ready to set up our local
environment to start developing will do
this by copying the project's git
repository URL then we can run a git
clone to pull the project locally
I've now opened the project in Visual
Studio code here we can see it includes
all the configuration and source files
that are needed to build and deploy our
project for more information on local
development be sure to check out our
other videos on using the IBM cloud
developer tools command-line interface
last but not least let's switch back to
our browser and view the kubernetes
dashboard when I hit refresh
you can see here that our project has
been deployed we can see that our
deployment
pods
services
and even the secrets that contain
authentication credentials to access our
IBM services the IBM cloud app service
makes it simple to start building new
cloud native applications you can get
started today by visiting cloud at